all right and here we are with our chaos
scene and we are ready to animate so the
big thing with this is that
I want to set up we have all these
adjustments right and we have all these
parameters that we can change
and all these different
things that affect the way that our
image looks
if you were to animate this especially
if you're going to change this word or
if you're going to change
you know from scene to scene
as I did in this type of animation
it's really hard to adjust all of those
parameters on so many different layers
and here is my just to give you an idea
of what I'm talking about these are all
my animation keyframes for this there's
60 layers
for this typography
um
intro
60 layers and a lot of keyframes it's
very easy to animate this it's not hard
but it's just it becomes overwhelming
sometimes when you have so many
parameters to change on so many
different layers
so the way we can combat that is to set
up a new adjustment layer and call this
adjustments
let's color this Orange
and let's go through and use
expression controls if you go to x
effect
expression controls and then a slider
control
and I'm going to duplicate this a bunch
of times
maybe put like 15 in there that's fine
and then what I want to go through is
anything that I might want to animate to
change the look
I want to make an adjustment for over
here so off the top of my head I know
camera lens blur is going to be one
and what I can do then is go to the
adjustment click this lock layer
come down here click the arrow go to
effects or I believe
the letter e yeah the letter e gives you
all of your effects underneath this
layer and now I can go and click the
camera lens blur and then take this
little pick whip
and put it up here to the slider and
you'll see that my number changes here
and you'll see that my design will
change because the slider is now
controlling this parameter
so if I put 60 in like I had before
there you go we're back to where we are
but the cool thing about this is is now
I can animate this one parameter if I
click on this layer and hit you
I can move a couple frames and maybe
take this down to 30.
[Music]
and again this is where it gets a little
CPU intensive
because you're addressing so many things
that deal with practical noise and
um Distortion it can get a little hectic
sometimes on your processing
but
that's where this adjustment layer
really helps save time so
go through what I want to do is
horizontal
displace
type
vertical displace type
let's do fractal
o1 let me type this correctly fractal 01
random seed
[Music]
fractal O2 random seed
see here what else we want uh there is
gaussian blur on here
on our main typography
gaussian blur type
Global glow width and all that means is
just anything that I say Global means to
these layers up here
so these are the layers that affect the
overall image so you can just say
overall global
whatever you would like uh
and let's just leave it at that for now
so
I can delete all those and then with
this continually being locked let's go
and set up the displacement map now I
have two in here but the displays that
I'm talking about is
[Music]
see if it's that one
the other one
yeah
is it the other one
let's just put 01 behind here and then
let's duplicate these
and go 0202 so I have horizontal
displaced type 01 vertical 01 horizontal
01 or horizontal O2 vertical O2 and
that's just gonna talk about my
displacement map
01 and displacement map
O2 okay
so o1 is going to have a Max here and uh
right now it's at 39 so let's set this
to 39 once we clamp it
the vertical is set to 56 so let's go to
56.
and then let's go to displacement map O2
and do the same thing
this was -10 right
and this vertical is 30.
all right now I can go to fractal one
random seed and remember the random
seeds here
the random seed has to do with the look
and the way
the pattern of this so I want to be able
to change this pattern on the Fly and
that's what I'm setting up now
so let's go back to adjustments clamp
this down
fractal 01 scroll down here to Evolution
options and then random seed
so let's click and drag that and this
was set to three before I did that and
you can see now it's back to three and
the red numbers mean that an expression
has been used and this is just saying
that this comp layer is tied to slider
and the slider name
and the slider will control all of this
if you delete this slider you're going
to get an expression error or if I undo
and if you accidentally delete this
adjustments you're going to get an
expression error now really the
expression error doesn't really
affect anything except for the fact that
you kind of have broken links now in
your document so once you set this up
try not to delete anything
because it might be hard to find what
has been deleted
fractal O2
this I'm going to duplicate and then I'm
also going to say fractal O2 expansion
mask expansion so I can take this now if
I turn on my mask
and take my mask expansion
I gotta keep this locked
mask expansion here and go to that right
there
let me uh yeah I'm good
so now what I can do if I turn this on
and off
if I turn this mask expansion up
it is going to increase the area of my
mask
now you can't see that with here because
the mask expansion kind of works in the
background but I'm expanding this mask
by 31 pixels so if I have a big design
like in my original one I have this a
here my mask expansion I'm probably
gonna want to be a lot larger than
something like this where my mask
expansion I'm going to want like one or
two pixels if anything at all because
this type is so small so this is where
you get that control this is where you
really get to hone in your design
let's set that back to zero the effect
fractal noise
Evolution options and tie the random
seed to that guy
and then gaussian blur type let's go
back up here collage and blur blurriness
is at a 10.
so let's set this back to 10 and there
we go we're back to where we're at and
then the overall glow now here I have I
originally had one as glow and now I
have two glows so you might have to
do
two because I don't think you can tie
two separate things to one slider but
let's try that
so what I want to do is do the glow
radius because that is my size right and
I want this to be 150
and the glow radius is different here so
yes we have to do two sliders
so let's go glow with a one
duplicate it Glow with O2 let's actually
take this here
and then let's change this to 200. you
know you can re-tie a link and now this
glow width is not tied to the top one
and then just reset everything and there
you go so now what I can do with the
parameters that I've set up I can
animate that stuff
so the first thing that I want to do is
let's go into
our
typography and maybe let's animate this
stuff coming on
letter by letter
[Music]
and I'm just kind of making things
random here
and
let's actually do this two letters at a
time so boom boom boom
and then let's bring this back six so it
goes blank blank blank blank
[Music]
all right and now I want to go to
position
and create some secondary motion
so when this comes in let's toggle hold
keyframe
set this in the beginning let's actually
do that for all of these
toggle hold keyframe at the beginning so
they're all centered up to where they
need to be
and then when this s comes on
let's actually have that
slide over here
the O and the S and let's have that
slide in over here
and then let's have the o
come back to this oops
let's have it come a few frames and
let's have it come back to this
position
I'm going to make that a full Square
and then let's go a little bit over
and then
back to where we
originally wanted it to land so this is
how I did the animation
I had things kind of pop on with stop or
hold keyframes
and then some things came in and then I
had secondary motion added to them so
let's play that through
whoops oops
pull this a little bit tighter
so it just looks like things are getting
clicked into place and what I want to do
too is add the a when the O moves I want
the a now
to come
down and then when the S comes in I want
this to kind of split and go right back
to where it was
let's make that a square
a full hold keyframe
so you see how these are coming and kind
of plopping in and out of place and
interacting with each other now so
that was
maybe I just hold this out a little bit
up too much
maybe I take these two keyframes and
pull them in
you can sit here that looks pretty good
you can sit here and mess with that all
day get your timing right so now I have
uh let's go back to this
let's turn all of my effects off
and now I have
to go down to quarter so I can render
this a little bit quicker
see things come on
in that fashion but now I can take it
one step further okay
oops let's not turn on my
[Music]
and I can animate all of these
parameters that I set up
so let's set up all of these sliders
here to you and the keyboard
and
let's make them hold keyframes you can
also go back right click toggle hold
keyframe
and let's go through here and maybe
make the gaussian blur where's the
gaussian blur at right here okay let's
make this
super high
100 pixels
and as things come in
like that now I can drop it back down to
like 50.
and maybe let's do
a new random seed of one
maybe let's do five
that could work
and then you're just kind of going frame
by frame and not frame by frame per se
but every few frames just kind of seeing
what works maybe let's change this guy
in
maybe let's change the blur back down to
what it was which was 10.
uh glow width I don't want to mess with
maybe vertical displacement will go up
to 50.
Maybe
let's take it up to 75 and really kind
of Crank It Up There
let's do vertical of 20.
and again I'm on quarter so
turn this to let's do a half maybe
uh 100
there you go
and
[Music]
then let's go back to
the beginning of where we were at
and let's play this and see what we get
here comes my C nice and blurry
[Music]
and things are going to be grungy
kind of snap into place there
and you can animate that all day
but you see the effect that you get you
can have different looks within this
and intertwine everything together
so that is the whole fact
how you set up the rig what I want to
show now is how I did this and just a
quick overview here are all my keyframes
and all my sliders and
fit this into our comp here and you can
see here's my starting point
and all of the different sliders that I
had set up inside of here
so here the blurs start kicking into
high gear
they're a little bit thicker can you see
from this scene to this scene see how
much Distortion I added in there
[Music]
you know so these things are really
moving and grooving in here but it's
just these small little adjustments from
scene to scene
frame to frame and one thing that I
loved here is this
transitions
this this Distortion layer that was the
mask expansion layer the fractal O2
really cranking up the horizontal
displacement on this helped the
transition between the A and the g
so you can see how it just kind of
distorts into and it's a little abrupt
right there between there and there
but you can see how it helps distort
and break up that transition so we're
not just popping things on and off and
here you go when one thing is clear I
like to grunge it up and drop it back
and then bring it clear again maybe
bring it back clear with a different uh
random seed on my fractal
and then here is the camera lens blur
taking over
and that's really really strong so my
camera lens blur
is set to
50 right here
and
the glow width is set to 48 so a High
glow
and then we're back to cleaning it up
it's grungy it's it's blurry
you can see the blur map here
half the screen and then we're going to
clean it back up here's our distort see
the the bubbleizing of the Distortion in
that Center
we're gonna straighten it out again
just in time for the W transition and
here you go really really grungy really
really distorted
clean it back up
heavy heavy blur on the camera lens blur
and the
type gaussian blur I guess is what is
actually doing that
[Music]
um
the camera lens blur too can do that so
whichever one and there's the camera
lens blur so that's how you get the S
being in clear and then the fractal
noise wherever the fractal noise kind of
sits is what is going to be blurry
that's from the camera lens blur layer
so
hope that helps I hope that shows too
like how easy some of this stuff can be
and when it's all said and done very
quickly within a few hours you know you
have a nice intro typography animation
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so that's it that's the whole process
black and white typography building our
effects our grunge effects over top and
then animating that rig so we can easily
move from look to look to look it's a
super fun technique and you don't really
have to use it just for typography you
can use it for images videos really
anything you want to grunge up so
experiment have some fun if you do
create something Post in the community I
love seeing it I know camera does as
well and until next time my name is Ryan
with motion science see you soon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]